so Who am I I'm 21 year old guy from the
Netherlands I study in Rotterdam I've
been playing chess for quite a while
since I was 8 years old became an
international master at 14 and a
grandmaster at 16 at the time I was the
youngest chess grandmaster in the
Netherlands that record has been broken
so let's not talk about that too much
so I want to talk a little bit before I
go to the game over here I'm being a
professional chess player in Europe is a
little different than being a
professional chess player in the US the
there's two major differences when you
go to a tournaments and your Grandmaster
most of the time your peon tournaments
are going to offer you a kind of a
sponsorship they're gonna pay for your
flight your hotel in many cases or at
least your hotel and a lot of your
expenses are covered sometimes meals as
well and so on in the US that's not
really the case if you go to an open
tournament it's like the jungle right
I've only played one u.s. tournament
well I had to take my own board and you
know that also doesn't happen in Europe
so there's quite a big difference in the
tournament play but also we have leaks
we have lots of chess leagues in Europe
so as a chess professional what you like
to do is to play some leagues because
then you go there for a weekend you play
a couple games your team pays you for
that and it's nice you meet a lot of
colleagues and you don't always have to
play against everyone you also have
people on your side so that's a nice
thing and I play in quite a few leaks I
playing the Dutch league the Belgian
League the German league the Icelandic
league so I have all these leagues and
you know you try to get into as many as
possible because it's fun and it's nice
this one was played in the German league
now this is actually a new team for me
this was this year and so I'm a new guy
in the team a lot of pressure but it
went pretty good for me so I'm playing
for one of the one of the best teams in
the league I would say so League on for
the last ten years
the German Bundesliga has been won by
baden baden so they're like
dominating the leak right these guys are
really good
they're almost only 2700 players and our
team is doing really really well we're
beating everyone we're beating you know
teams that are slightly stronger than us
we're beating teams that are slightly
weaker but we're beating everyone so
we're in first place
and then comes the day on a Sunday that
we have to play bottom balance so it's
really exciting big match might very
well decide the winner of the whole
league problem 1 the leak on Sunday
starts at 9 a.m. now I don't know about
you guys but I'm not the best chess
player at 9 a.m.
problem 2 I want a pretty lucky game on
Saturday so I've announced to my team
because I've been playing really well in
this league and I like really pumped up
for this match I've announced I'm gonna
win the game I'm saying guys guys I mean
I got this like I'm gonna play some
2,700 players some really strong
grandmaster kind of had an idea who I
was gonna play because normally you call
you show up on Saturday with a team and
you play in the afternoon and most teams
play with the same team on Sunday well
you can sort of get you see where this
is going right so I'm expecting to play
some guy who didn't really play a very
good game on Saturday and I'm confident
I'm saying okay guys he's the weak
player we're talking like former world
champion over here so a little bit
optimistic but I think like okay I have
a chance against this guy Dwight and I
prepared everything's good I show up at
9:00 a.m. well not really it was a
little bit later than 9:00 a.m. but
excuse me right so I show up a little
bit later than 9:00 a.m. and I see see
the guy sitting so I walk up to the
board but then I see there's already one
of my teammates sitting so what's going
on right like so I look a little bit
forward I'm very sleepy at this point I
see Levon Aronian and Vishwanath on
amnon city all I mean those guys playing
this thing feels Cup I'm not that level
right but suddenly from Saturday Sunday
these guys fly in and they're ready
they're ready to beat us right like
we're we're first in the league
so I'm playing someone completely
different
I'm playing Radha Lavoie taschek and
I've already lost a game previously to
him and what I like about chess is it's
really nice to win a game it's even
better to get revenge and this is this
is a story of revenge now for those who
are in my previous lecture unfortunately
the people online couldn't see it you
know I start out I'm kind of thinking
what should I show the people so go to
my own database right I'm just like okay
highest ratings that's scrolling it's
from like oh I beat this guy so there
you go here I'd be the 2700 player not
really but in the previous the previous
lecture I showed my gaming has Bing Lee
ran that I won so this is another story
I promise I'm gonna humble myself a
little bit this time I'm gonna briefly
show you the guy the game that I lost to
this guy just to get an impression of my
mindset during this game right so
normally I play E for now the people
here can see I started with c4 so
there's already something strange about
that let's see what happened to me being
a theoretical player
I like theory I like to enter lines that
are complicated that you analyze with
the computer a lot unfortunately my
opponent from Poland the number one in
Poland he's kind of playing like me in a
way except that he's a little bit better
at everything especially in opening so
this game you know this happened around
a year before we're playing on the
Bundesliga so we're entering some
Sicilian
the details are not really important
some line I was very confident I'll
analyze this a lot I spent hours and
hours analyzing this variation right so
I was good this is all my analysis and
suddenly this guy placed this move Queen
to c7 so I'm thinking like okay clearly
my idea is to go d4 right I mean we want
to capture the center so I'm sitting
there for boom like whoa I have no Queen
c7 like why don't you try to develop
your other pieces you're not supposed to
play with the Queen so early on in the
game so I go d4 take an untidy four and
then he plays this move rook c8 and now
I'm thinking to myself like jeez that's
attacking my bishop but okay that
shouldn't be a problem now mind you this
was also a mourning game so this
explains my state of mind
little bit so I'm like okay you know
he's attacking my bishop I'm gonna take
it out and then this move happens in the
morning as well and after Bishop takes
e4 after Bishop takes e4 Bishop takes e4
I want to take when my route credits a
piece
oops and there it is I'm lost
so I played some other moves and to be
fair other games have followed this
after after I fell for this and it's not
all that bad but let's just say black is
a little bit better out of opening and
I'm playing a very strong player so this
was kind of a sad story and now I'm
facing him again in the morning and I'm
thinking to myself okay what do I do
so emergency plan playing 1c for now I
don't want to say that it has some kind
of great strategy over here and it was
like a masterpiece but what I do like
about this game is that to my mind what
sets apart the very best players from I
don't want to say guys like me but let's
say strong grandmasters 2600 players
it's very often they manage to retain a
little bit of tension in positions that
are almost equal so even if they're not
better or if they don't really have an
advantage they manage to play moves in
which the opponent cannot just liquidate
to a drop drawn position and they keep
doing that and doing that and very often
people do make mistakes and when I think
about Carlsen that's one of the ways he
wins all the time
he doesn't necessarily get advantages
out of the opening and he manages to win
anyway and mostly because of this he's
out playing people from equal positions
now that's not normally what happens to
me I tried again an advantage from the
opening and then I try to take it from
there win the game especially when I'm
playing grandmasters of this level so I
played c4 I don't have that much
knowledge here and as you can probably
guess this is one of the few examples
where I did manage to play quite a good
game and I did manage to turn something
very small into into a win so what we
have over here is it's kind of a hybrid
of a Catalan so my bishops really nice
but the difference is that I haven't
moved my pawn from d2 to d4 yet so I'm
kind of flexible on the other hand I
allow black
to capture the center with d4 as well
but having played the Benoni myself that
was not my biggest worry so played b3
over here I can't play d4 here of course
it's the Catalan it's a big opening but
once again I'm not really a d4 player
not really familiar with all this stuff
so I got to try to stay a little bit
more within the range that I understand
so b3 if d4 here okay we get sort of a
benoni like position so something like
this something like this and I didn't
have all that much knowledge here but
it's a structure that I understand I've
played these kind of positions with
black to give you an example play put
the rook on you one play D 3 something
like 93 95 or 93 92 at least the plans
here are familiar to me and I'm not
gonna lose my central pawn like I did in
the last game so hey it can't be all
that bad
it's a little bit better than last time
so I was ready for this and my opponent
played c5 now Oh Bishop b2 still if it
goes d4 I mean this is theory it's it's
right playable for both sides Knight to
c6 now this is kind of a problem I mean
I can play III over here I think people
do play this but he doesn't necessarily
have to go d4 right he could go I don't
know b6 or something like that so it's
already time for me to sort of decide
what I'm gonna do it do in the center so
I'm not super familiar with this at this
point I'm taking on d5 now what I do
know is that he goes e to X d5 I will
play d4 and ok I don't have to know all
that much to understand the structure
over here this is an isolated pawn
position and this looks very safe for
white I'm gonna move my knight probably
90 to 93 or maybe I'll put it even on c3
and try to attack this pawn some more
but this is not something I need to know
all that much about you to play a good
game ok my upon plays Knight XD 5 now
Knight XD 5 is a more solid move because
black wants to play Bishop f6 and of
course he's not compromising a sponsor
so if I go d4 now which I did play but
if I go d4 then once he takes and I take
back which happen in the game as we can
see he's not going to get an isolated
pawn anytime soon there are some options
with that in the game first of all I
must say this is not really a variation
which is all that exciting really black
can play b6 as well I found out later
and I think this is also very playable I
more or less have to develop my knight
he takes he goes we should the v7 I mean
as you can see this is really not not
super exciting it's a game okay he took
on d4 he played quite quickly still and
I found out that a couple of games of
Kramnik replay here that were played
here and that's a good sign
so it shows that there is a little bit
of a little bit of play to what I'm
doing over here without knowing it of
course I only found out after the game
but for example Nakamura here played
Knight XD for which I don't really like
Queen takes d4 threatens made on g7 and
Bishop to f6 is kind of the logical move
Queen at e2 and here it could exchange
but that would also invite white to play
rip to d1 I mean as you can see the pawn
structures here are fairly fairly equal
right what I'm playing for is this
Bishop on g2 which is always going to
dominate a bishop on c8 if I play it
well nakamura played the move Bishop to
d7 but here actually the Kramnik took on
d5 and played through t1 and again we
see kind of a isolated plant structure
it's not that hard for played too wide
to play as wide I'm gonna go be sure to
d4 Knight to c3 my King might be a
little weak but for the moment I mean he
could put his Bishop on h3 but it's far
from eight right so again this type of
position I'll be happy to play so you
can get into a little bit of trouble
here it's black
another option was playing Bishop to f6
immediately this is always a question is
black you can play a little bit more
actively but you allow Knight takes c6 B
takes
six which most grandmasters are not
going to do that because that's kind of
a long-term weakness right so after it
takes takes let's say queen you see one
is an interesting move we could also
take and play Knight d2 it's a little
bit better here we're playing for a
trick as white because after Knight to
c3 which looks very annoying we have
this move Knight to e4 and later on in
the game we also see that these type of
structures can happen and generally
white is very happy to to enter any kind
of ending or any position if black is
not too active where he can just press
on this pawn on c6 and sort of double up
on that maybe block block it later on in
the game so this is why it's three it's
not something outstanding but it will be
very annoying for blacks of defense so
going back to the game Knight XD four he
played Bishop to d7 now I can't play
Bishop takes d5 but I don't like it that
much because he hasn't exchanged the
Knights yet so if I take on c6 here he's
gonna play B takes get gets his hanging
pawns but these are a little bit more
flexible because he can move it up to c5
and this can also become a strength
later on in the game imagine he goes c5
d4 shuts out my bishop I mean this could
be a good thing for black as well so the
more pieces that are on in these types
of positions if if I don't have my
bishop here now my King can actually get
a lot weaker I just don't want to have
too many pieces on this position so I
decided not to go for Bishop takes d5
play Knight to c3 instead in this
position so you might ask like okay
Robin I mean come on you you've
announced that you're gonna win the game
and here you are trying to exchange all
the pieces kind of true but still there
is a little bit of venom in this
position I mean if I play 90 X III beat
X III Bishop takes c3 which was played
in the game the simplest move is to play
90 x d4 right trying to exchange
everything but here we see these bishops
are pretty nice and I again Bishop to c6
you can decide to do that but after
Bishop takes c6 b2 x e6 we're getting
into that position again and nobody
likes to play these kind of these kind
of positions where you're just
struggling for equality for the rest of
the game
and I have any weaknesses I'm gonna
press on the C pawn similar story as
before so he goes route the c8 much more
solid move now he might have had used to
go Knight takes d4 and Bishop to c6 in
some cases but still if he decides to do
that he might have to watch out for the
a7 phone so okay I'm playing route to c1
now he took on d4 here which is close to
equal it's all close to equal but it's
probably not the best move he could have
played Bishop to a3 over here and after
rooks he to Queen e7 now he actually has
a nice square for his queen where I
can't really attack it but one of the
things here is that if he goes Queen b6
or something like that I'm not quite
sure but I think there's move such as
Knight to f5 to watch out for
so I'm attacking these the bishop on d7
is hanging as well and of course you
know another thing that I might hope for
is some sort of a position with the
bishop pair so in in this position I'm
I'm happy might not be much better but I
have the bishops it's not gonna be easy
for him to exchange he has a double palm
so we'll play it instead after Bishop a3
rootsy 227 nice got the bishop covered
he's ready to go rook to d8 hit my queen
and this is a little bit awkward I think
I think this is fairly easy to equalize
for example Roxy d2 now Bishop to c6 and
after after things related to Bishop
takes a 7 we're having some sort of
trick let me see what the trick is so we
have probably ideas with Bishop to b4
over here followed by rook to e8 and
rook takes a 2 there was there some
tricks here okay
okay another move here by the way to
sort of make my point is you can go b6
this is one of those cases where you're
like all the computer says which it
takes a 7 is on the big deal but ok b6
followed by Bishop c6 similar ideas as
you can see not that much just or am i
blundering I'm blundering mysticism ok
guys let's just say that the position
was not so not so easy maybe maybe we
should take maybe Bishop to b4 what's
the right move for
32 so okay something like this but as
you can see I'm trying to equalize his
black and I'm making blunders so this
can happen to my opponent as well
proving my point in a funny way okay so
he goes nighty-night XD for now Queen
takes d4 okay Bishop takes d4 as
possible but then he might take on c1 go
something like Queen to b8 and again
it's very little if he can once again if
he can exchange the light squared bishop
then it's really done then my life - is
gone this is my main source of hoping
for anything so I got Queen takes
because he might exchange the dark
squared bishop but I still have a little
bit of pressure over here so Queen d3 is
what I played and actually he had it he
had a very strong move over here which
I'm gonna give you and the viewers
online just a minute to see how this is
the position in the game I allowed
something which I shouldn't have allowed
my opponent didn't sting go for it but
there's a nice little move that helps
him to equalize over here yes Bishop to
b5 okay tricky move Oh
Bishop to b5 let's see well first of all
what happens if I take on CAS is this
working I'm not sure because if you take
on d3 I take on d8 you have a lot of
pieces hanging and I still have this
rook over here right so that's not good
and if you take on c8 with the Queen I'm
taking your Bishop seems to work out for
Y if you take on the three with the
Queen take on our favor check right so
it doesn't quite solve your problems now
some of you probably saw my move but
anyone wants to suggest what the best
movies instead of Bishop to b5 yeah
Bishop c6 well but then you're then
you're getting into the position that I
love right over here are you defending
this one again I mean it's it's not that
bad for for black I will be worried
about that but something to play for
here something to play for because also
let's not forget if you're trying to
become active over here I've got that
minor advantage which is actually quite
important now that after taking on c6
you're still dealing with the background
background mate so again it's little but
I would gladly play it no black it you
could make use of a tactic over here
Queen f6 that's a pretty good move I
would say very close to the idea that
I'm thinking of if I take on on c8 and I
go rook to d1 the slight difference to
to what my suggestion is is that I
wouldn't have time for Brooke to Tijuana
which I'm still sort of at least
preventing your book on on afraid to get
into the game and if you play b6 who
knows I might have time to create
something like Queen d6 Queen c7 again
we're playing for very slight advantages
but maybe even some kind of some other
move because your bishop can't move your
route can move so you're dealing with
some slot small problems
what I'm talking about is actually the
move Queen to a5 this is very clever
now Queen to a5 same ideas Queen f6 I
can take on d7 cuz rooks hanging and
after route exceed Bishop take c8 again
you might say okay I don't have that
much squares my I want to go rook to d1
but the a to pawn is hanging right so
that's a small small difference but in
this case I might have to go a for you
go over to d8 and now we see okay on the
next move you're probably gonna go g6 or
h6 and we're really talking about an
equal position at this point so I have
to be very careful with white I mean
it's minor things that are keeping me
still continuing this game and I'm
pushing a little bit so they should have
played Queen to a5 I missed it honestly
he played rook takes c3 instead I was
very happy to see this move I take back
and again Queen to b6 he wants to go
route to c8 if he goes rook c8 and
Bishop c6 but we know by now it's
probably I'm gonna be equal and so which
move do you think I played yeah
very good played rook to c1 again we
still have a little bit of a back ranked
issue right so rook c8 Queen takes e8
we're winning what would you do is black
in this position you know knowing that
you want to play rook c8 you can't quiet
yep yep
g6 smart guy my opponent didn't play g6
but I think g6 might be a better move
now I can't quite explain this to you
yet because it would give away a lot of
the exercises about the calm but keep
this in mind why could g6 maybe be a
little bit better than h6 you can
already try to think about it a little
bit eight-six is also very logical right
so he goes h6 yes Bishop b4 okay you're
I mean there there might be something of
the sort that I could hopefully one day
get to here or at least I can prevent
his king from coming to h7 right so
that's the reason but there's a little
bit more to it than that so first of all
in this position again it's my move
right and actually in these types of
games you'd be surprised maybe if you
see a position like this and I don't
want to compare myself to any of these
players but who is really good at these
players the Magnus Carlsen Karpov you
know guys who sometimes are considered
to have a slightly boring style the
interesting thing about this is that in
my opinion these types of position
require the most alkylation out of all
of them they require calculation you
need to be very good at tactics because
as you can see every single move has to
be on point
I already made a couple moves that are
you know so so I'll ask immune to a5
Magnus Carlsen would probably find a way
to stop Queen a5 and keep that small
pressure that I have right now but for
me right now it's you know it's getting
a bit later maybe it's 1 o'clock at this
point actually if not 1 o'clock it's
probably more like 12 and I'm feeling a
look no it's not about guys it's like 10
o'clock sorry it's Jennifer
I remember how I felt here so it's 10
o'clock and I'm like okay I'm still
happy I'm sipping my coffee you know
waking up a little bit and I'm liking my
position because it's very risk-free I'm
not losing today but I still promised my
team I should win so that's not really
holding up today I mean this guy's got
like 27 40 which draws normally it's
okay right
although I should be ambitious but I
actually said I was gonna win so what do
I do now okay I see an interesting idea
where I see Queen to e5 and can anyone
tell me why Queen to e5 might be might
be an interesting move or a strong move
yeah I'm gonna play rook
yeah rook c7 probably do you know why I
cannot play Queen to c7 over here
rook the c8 right look let's have a
quick look at that Queen c7 looks very
nice right because if I can exchange
this than well this is probably over
already I'm attacking everything but he
has this good idea route to c8 so he's
using a little bit of tactics as well to
defend himself now if I take the bishop
my recon she wants hang so okay I can do
that but rook the c7 looks nice indeed
so I'm thinking okay and he could go at
six for example but f6 I can go Queen to
e4 attacking his b7 pawn and if he goes
Bishop to c6 now suddenly it already
shows that his positions a little bit
loose right he's six pawn is hanging who
knows maybe one day I'll be very brief
and jump into here if it's possible like
there's some weaknesses around the
scheme he doesn't want to play f6 here
so how does black solve his problems at
this point I'm gonna give you a couple
of minutes to think about this because
this is actually tough position if you
want to I can even switch the board but
I'm probably not going so I'm gonna make
it really hard for you but think about
this for a couple minutes how do we
defend here's black that we already come
to the point where it looks like it's
you know almost nothing but maybe we're
in trouble
you got an idea Rick CA okay so after
rook c8 probably have to take that right
how much I can do here you have any
ideas over yours yep Queen the b8 right
not that easy
in fact we're doing really quite bad
here as black I mean we have this this
pin over here we need to defend it one
way or another and no matter where we go
we're going to push it Bishop takes b7
so any normal move loses and even on top
of that if it doesn't lose then the a
pawn will be hanging so this shows that
the natural move doesn't quite work so I
was feeling very proud at this point in
the game I was like okay if he finds the
defense that's cool
but I managed to put some pressure on it
you know I really tried my best
any other ideas
my opponent spent some time over here I
came up with a very tactical idea so my
question to you is what move do we want
to play really really badly and why are
we not playing it which move do we love
to play here is black Bishop c6 what's
the problem with it right I create that
weakness that I'm talking about so after
Bishop c6 takes takes I'm gonna go
something like Queen at c5 and it's not
gonna be very nice right I mean you're
gonna sit on this pawn you're not gonna
be able to move too much not too much
counter place so we don't like that but
hold on a second do we have to take back
rook c8 right so this is exactly what
happened in the game I mean I got to
take on c6 right and then rip the c8
happens now in all honesty what's about
to happen here in my opinion is still
like I'm surprised at how complicated
this position is but I will be very
honest I didn't see this idea of Bishop
to c6 and ricocheted I missed it now
we're gonna give you guys a little bit
of time and I advise the viewers as well
to do so and figure out what exactly is
going on here because black wants to you
know we know what blacks move is gonna
be on next move and I can give you one
hint okay he's gonna play route 66 if I
play I play just any move I got rook
Shih Tzu or something and he goes for
this let's say now with the Queen's on
it's not quite the same I'm first of all
can block the pawn on c5 but also with
just Queens is much easier for me to or
for black to create some counter play
the only way for me to make progress
over here just to bring my King over
right but that's very ambitious I mean
and while I'm doing that in the course
of doing that probably some pawns are
gonna be hanging and so on so in the
Queen ending where it's a whole
different ball game this is very draw
ish so let's keep that in mind and try
to figure out how do we make something
out of this as wife
okay let's say root c4 and if he takes
that maybe check here and which movie
would you like to play Luke the f4 or
something like that yeah I mean there is
a little bit of initiative I think I
think should be able to protect against
this maybe even something slightly
passive like rook to c7 would suffice
also I have to be a bit careful not that
I get checked on c1 and Queen c6 check
probably right now it's still still okay
we can play f3 although you know there
could be some counter play over here
imagine I go Queen to b5 and I'm hitting
this pawn it doesn't seem like I'm quite
in control over here but the suggestion
is is decent so again let's let's have a
look at this position
group the c-4 definitely feels like one
of the more active moves right if anyone
has at least to improve on the line or a
different idea so is this just to draw
guys I mean there were people
embarrassing right given the story yeah
I played them over to see for my
opponents you know those guys have good
poker faces by the way does 2700 players
but my opponent he he got a little bit
shocked suddenly I could I could tell so
he saw something I had seen it at this
point as well some traps and what
happened here is very strange I he was
thinking and thinking and thinking I
think 30 or 40 minutes I came to the
board and I saw that he he's not
comfortable and he certainly plays the
move BTech c6 so ok first of all be take
c6
I mean this is the position that we that
we like right here we have some chances
but there is more to it this is actually
the worst moment to play b takes c6 that
we've seen so far why is this the worst
moment
the rookin see yet its passive sure but
there's something very concrete here
this is a lost position if I go Gees
roof take g6 right very good
so route 86 suddenly not only is it
passive it's just hanging and I got this
Queen ending with two pawns up well you
know I know how to win that that should
be too hard right so okay this is what
happens but this is not the end of the
story g5 was played okay that doesn't
lose immediately but here I go Queen f6
I'm attacking the H pawn king h7 Queen
takes f7 check it's all falling apart
right so over here I don't even have to
find really hard moves at this point he
resigns so well that was nice you know I
kept my promise teammates came up to me
this game ended in about two hours and I
want to brag but I'm very proud of this
but what exactly is going on here
because after the game I got a lot of
messages from my friends a lot of them
professional chess players saying Ah
Robin your lucky guy you know you just
blunder it like that was nothing so you
know why did they all say that well I'm
gonna do something very risky right now
and I hope it's gonna work I'm going to
turn on the engine and see what it says
0.60 imeem that's not winning right 0.80
if you take another engine it's gonna
say 0.20 that's what the engine online
said when the game was broadcasted so
there's something that engines don't see
now in my experience the only thing that
engines really don't see sometimes when
you don't let them run for too long it's
something very very deep so we're about
to do something really really deep a
very deep line so roof takes c6 is the
obvious move right this was the whole
idea
why didn't he play this move yeah
mmm-hmm take on c6 very good so this is
what this is what he was thinking about
right one more time
I play queen bee I check King h7 very
very good great job like wind eh a king
h7 now he's got to decide how to take
back if he goes Queen takes c6 okay sure
it's only a pawn he might have some
drawing chances but there's nothing very
direct over here that's gonna give him a
draw for example he can give a check
with f3 okay the game is going on here
so he definitely didn't want to go for
this cuz the chances are let's say 5050
that he loses Edward but he draws it so
B takes c6 is what you would like to
play and the engines initially said okay
this is just a draw right so let's have
a look how do you want to create the
outside pass pawn what what's the most
obvious move I hear a four that's yeah
yeah a four okay actually we're not
actually going to make that outside pass
pawn it's not that simple if he goes a
four I mean sure if he brings the king
then it's it's over right before a5 my
pawn is you know much faster and my King
can defend against the C pawn life's
good but he goes c5 now the same goes
for if he if we go before he goes b5
right so we got to decide but let's say
he goes but I I go a 45 how do we
evaluate this position especially you
know coming all the way back from when
still Queen B a check and so has to be
played the easiest way to figure out
what's going on in such a position is to
really really boil it down to the most
forcing moves
so I'm gonna give you guys a couple
minutes you're not too tired try to find
not like you know something interesting
something nice I want you to really
really find the most forcing moves if I
play this move he has to play that move
then I play this move he's forced to do
this try to go as far as possible with
that and we'll get you to the solution
King f1 okay so what's your idea with
King f1
okay so King f1 what does black do King
King g8 or King g6 I would go I'm gonna
go King g6 before okay I'm gonna keep
running Oh before King f6 key to King e5
in d3 now you got a you know it's very
tricky but I think I can play g5 let's
just say it's it's interesting King see
force possible King takes e4 King B 5
and then King f3 and my Epona's rang
this is a crazy line let's not go too
far but my point is that we've played
efore and I like the movie for but it's
giving us some options you know I don't
have to play g5 maybe go King b6 maybe
we go at 5 let's try to keep it really
really simple ok
yeah now what I want from you guys is
really really the most straightforward
line if what what do we really want to
achieve here as wise what's her ideal a
passed pawn sure or we want to win upon
at least something like that what what
is the main tool like if we can just if
we can use like a parachute right now
and we're not talking about pawns
obviously because then you put on a 7 or
d7 where if we can parachute our King
right now to some place on the board
where it's feasible b5 so let's get the
King to b5 if the King comes to b5 we're
pretty sure we're winning this was my
logic when I was trying to call
like this what's the fastest way to be
five
we can go f1 or even go g2 it's not
rocket science it's two ways yeah
shouldering very good you've been
reading some chest books so what happens
if we go King f1 right he goes King here
and he's gonna show the ruffs right
unless he four is a different story but
we're trying to keep it simple
that's not what we want but now we're
shouldering him so we see this position
and funny thing is now we're getting the
same position with the King on d3 what's
the advantage of having the king on d3
d4 check getting a little close route to
b5 right so now we're getting this
position of course black has lots of
moves but the most obvious move is
stopping us from gaining space with E 5
because that's gonna limit his Oh his
amount of moves significantly so he's
gonna play e5 now believe it or not I
got to this point after a while and here
it's a matter of you know it's it's
really a matter of who can make the last
move here right because imagine imagine
just to show you the idea he goes king -
king to c7 b5 if we can make this work
one way or another he goes a 5 takes we
take King a six king c6 now this would
be a draw if all the pawns under Kings
eye were taken off right because he goes
a four but we know that that's not going
to be the case there's gonna be
something to run towards so in this
position if he has to make another move
and we both run out of moves on the King
side he's gonna play here and that's it
King to be 5 and we're good we're
winning so how do we figure out which
move to play over here
and this is what the computers initially
don't see computers okay so I f4 is
interesting and your your lines working
f6f-5 h5 is my only move and let's say H
for Allah and we're getting this I think
I'm not even 100 percent sure because
this one you might get to quicker than
this but let's see if this works
all right the annoying thing is he's
gonna take take and like play I don't
know probably probably g6 and now it's
getting really really hard to I mean
first of all to calculate but also I'm
not even sure it's winning right because
one of the one of the easy ways here he
v h5 actually this probably works this
probably works this probably works what
okay do we have other moles over here
yeah okay okay so question is okay it's
this winning I think there is a defense
my no BGC there's there might be f6 as
well I'm not sure about f6 again this is
this is really hard to calculate F 5 H 5
and if we're doing our trick now again
we're going for this type of position
rights imagine you're getting here okay
it might be winning don't quote me on
this but there might be it might be just
on time right might be but again I'm
trying to look for the easiest way here
I'm trying to look for the very easiest
way because f4 allows a lot of options
right and we're bringing it back almost
20 moves now so
keep me
kindiy three that's the type of position
a thing like maybe we could try to
triangulate something clever like that
but the problem is that whenever we
remove our King there's b5 and now we're
not really getting what we what we want
so better probably not touch the king
g4 okay can you I mean g4 is very
straightforward now we can move our F
and our H bonds so it's kind of easy to
calculate right h4 h4
h4 h5 a4 again this is one this is one
of the positions that I mean I would
never be sure about it in the game and
I'd okay I could have all analyzed it
and told you that this is obvious but I
like to keep it a little bit realistic
right I I still don't have a clue
basically so over here okay if we go
King d6 he runs to our B pawn and this
is kind of what I'm talking about
again it's it's probably winning
it looks like it's winning yeah looks
like it's winning yeah should be a win
as well
so after h4 the only thing I know is
that it's not so it might be might be g6
again
now you can probably go g4 which looks
very similar to the move you suggest if
g4 here which is my solution at the time
g4 hair g6 and h4 so h4 maybe is a good
alternate solution this black of annular
most of your d4 not really right because
if we go g5 right so h3 f6f-3 right so
to make this a little bit more fun
before I round up let's try to find out
what h4 is not working let's take a
couple minutes I mean the people online
are surely gonna find out let's try to
find out why it's not working they
always cheat using engines right
now g6g for looks like is I think I
think it's something like h5 f4 and then
takes exactly it takes takes I think
we're pretty much bound to play f6 for
g6 f6f-5 f6f-5 and here we start again
I'm not quite sure we take king c6 looks
like we're always on time over here this
should be winning as well yeah so
there's a lot of zooks rank positions
honestly it's not really the the point
of the exercise at the end of the day
it's more about trying to find a way
which you can which you can evaluate
easily from the start and for that
reason in my opinion g4 and the people
online might find the real defence g4 is
the right move because it prevents h5 if
g5 is obvious f6 what do we play after
f6 h 4g 6h five very good and again we
have six one right so who could have
known that's really my that's really my
point over here and I'm very sorry for
still not knowing about all the details
of the ending but I like it that way
because this is really how I thought
about it during the game and I will
study it one day but it doesn't fit the
story right I didn't really know what's
going on in the game I saw g4 that's all
I remember
I did find g4 the other alternate
solutions are a bit more complicated so
but who could have known in this
position that there's so much more to it
than then you can see at first sight and
well once again I was quite proud of
this game I thought it was a was a funny
story and an interesting interesting
game and most of all it was a very very
sweet revenge so thank you for watching
and
if you have any questions then please
feel free to ask